- [Dr. Sammy] Hi, everybody.
Dr. Sammy here, your friendly
neighborhood entomologist
here to talk to you about how adaptation,
which is dependent on the environment,
responds in contexts of
environmental change.
Natural selection promotes
adaptation in populations.
It encourages populations
to develop traits
that better allow individuals
to survive and reproduce.
Those adaptations are thus linked
to the environment in
which they were forged.
You can look at a lot of organisms
and based on their physical
traits and/or their behavior,
you can tell what sort of environment
their population likely evolved in.
So adaptations are products of,
and are inextricably
connected to, the environment.
But what happens when the environment
which forges a specific set of adaptations
no longer exists in that form?
How do populations respond?
Well, this happens to actually be
a pretty common occurrence on Earth.
I wouldn't be surprised if
the saying "things change"
was first coined by a paleontologist.
Studying the history of life on Earth
means you'd be well-acquainted
with the dogged persistence of change.
Well, the good news is the forces
that drive natural selection
don't just disappear when
an environment changes.
Because of the persistence
of heritable diversity
and differential survivorship
and reproduction,
natural selection is still
there to promote new adaptations
suited to the new
environmental conditions.
This means that when
the environment changes,
the distribution of
traits in the population
will often change as well.
What those changes will ultimately be
is based on the adaptations
promoted by the previous environment
and the pressures
presented by the new one.
So let's look at some examples
so I can make sure you're
picking up what I'm putting down.
Okay, so in evolutionary biology,
we like to discuss three
primary shift patterns
that can be observed as a
result of environmental change:
directional selection,
disruptive selection,
and stabilizing selection.
For each of these,
I'll show you a graph and tell you a story
of the stubbornness
and resilience of life,
because every graph has a story.
And the first of these stories
is that of directional selection.
The snow vole is a mouse-like
mammal that even I,
as an admittedly bug-biased scientist,
have to admit is pretty cute.
These rodents are born at high
elevations in the Swiss Alps
and researchers have observed something
that may seem obvious on its face.
Large adult snow voles
have better survivorship
than smaller adult snow voles.
They're more difficult for predators
to capture, overpower, and consume.
They have greater temperature tolerance
and typically more fat
stores for a long winter.
So historically, that
distribution of snow bowls...
Bowls.
Snow voles (laughing) has been shifted
toward the higher end of
the adult weight spectrum.
However, climate change has led to changes
in the snow vole's environment.
Snow has been falling earlier
and earlier in the Alps,
giving the voles less
time to actually develop.
If the voles haven't reached maturity
by the time the winter begins,
they typically can't
continue their lifecycle.
And because larger body sizes
require more time to develop,
there's a strong, selective
pressure against the genes
underlying larger body sizes
as the environment shifts
towards earlier winter onset.
This also means that the genes
underlying smaller body sizes are favored.
So the smallest individuals
in the original population
likely had the most offspring,
and the variation in those offspring
likely included some
that were even smaller
than in the original population.
This means that as the
smallest individuals
in each generation continue to be favored
and have the most offspring,
the distribution of the population
will likely continue to march to the left
until it reaches a point
where the individuals
are too small to do well given
the environmental conditions.
This shift can be represented by a graph
that shows directional selection.
Now let's go over the graph one more time
to make sure that everything is clear.
Here on the X-axis,
you'll see the spectrum
of average adult body size
ranging from the smallest
to the largest individuals.
Traits are quite frequently on a spectrum,
such that some individuals possess
a greater or lesser expression
and are thus differentially impacted
by environmental change.
On the Y-axis is the percent
of individuals in the population,
which allows you to see
proportionally how individuals fare
by comparison to those of
greater or lesser size.
The red arrow represents
selection pressure,
which in this case is imposed
by the abiotic factors of weather.
When looking at these graphs,
you wanna consider who is least able
to handle the pressure imposed.
It's typically the area
of the distribution
where you'll see the greatest difference
between the population before
and after the environmental change.
The white arrow then shows which direction
the population as a
whole is then shifting.
Directional selection events
are those which favor one extreme
while excluding another.
However, change itself can be as diverse
as the organisms it changes.
And thus, you can also get circumstances
where selection favors both extremes.
This is called disruptive selection.
For this example,
we look to the pungent
world of dung beetles.
Some populations of the
beetle Onthophagus acuminatus
have a bimodaled size distribution
where you'll see a large
number of large males
in addition to a large
number of small males
with very few representatives
of the sizes in between.
The large males use their superior size,
strength, and horns to fight other males
for the opportunity to mate.
A male having selected a mate
will spend most of his time
guarding the entrance to the
borough where she dwells,
grappling with males of
similar size who challenge him
for the chance to depose
him and mate with her.
Medium-sized males don't
do well in this context.
They can't overcome the larger males.
But why then are there small males
and why are they so
abundant in the population?
Well, they've actually got
a trick up their sleeves.
Instead of trying to fight,
they forgo the battle entirely
and simply use their diminutive size
to sneak past unnoticed.
These small males typically lack horns,
which leaves them similar
in appearance to females,
which makes male dung beetles
less inclined to engage them in battle.
And the little guys further avoid trouble
by deftly digging a backdoor entrance
into the female beetle's
subterranean nesting chamber,
such that they rarely have to encounter
the large male guarding the front door.
This allows them plenty of time to mate
before making their exit,
ensuring the representation
of their sneaky genetics in the gene pool.
Disruptive selection selects
for both extremes on the spectrum
to the exclusion of the moderate
trait in the distribution.
But there's also a form of selection
that is the opposite of
disruptive selection.
It's called stabilizing selection.
Stabilizing selection is
observed under circumstances
where selection is favoring
the moderate set of traits
in a distribution to the
exclusion of the extremes.
For this story, we once again turn
to the wondrous class Insecta,
where insects have learned to make a home
in some of the most
ingenious ways possible.
In the world of gall flies,
life begins when a female gall fly
lays an egg in the stem
of a suitable host plant.
The developing larva induces the plant
to form a spherical growth
around it called a gall,
which protects the
developing fly's squishy body
and provides it with all the food it needs
to reach adulthood,
unless a parasitic wasps shows up
and attempts to lay eggs
on the developing gall fly.
If this happens, the
developing wasp kills the fly
and takes over its living space.
This is easiest to do with small galls
because the wasp has to stick
his thin egg-laying tube
through the gall to
access the developing fly.
A large gall forms enough of a barrier
between the gall fly and
the wasp's egg-laying tube
that it can't quite make it.
So this selects for larger galls
and would promote directional selection,
all the other factors in
the environment being equal.
But what happens when
keen-eyed birds are introduced?
Well, large galls become
an easy meal for them
because they're conspicuous
in the environment.
This creates a situation
where small galls are selected
against as are large ones,
ensuring that the medium-sized
galls are favored.
To remember what this
distribution looks like,
I tell myself that the trait distribution
is being stabilized by
pressure on both sides.
Environmental change
can be pretty diverse.
Without the incredible adaptive
powers of natural selection,
our dynamic world would be unsuitable
for the unpredictability
that is life as we know it.